hello believe nation today I'm going to
talk about the seven ways to start your
perfect day so I'm a big believer in
morning routines I think that if you
start your day off right it carries
through to the rest of your day but if
you start your day off wrong negative
missing your first thing whatever that
first habit is you're supposed to do if
you miss that then you're likely to
cheat on the rest of it right like if
you say you're going to eat healthy and
then you start by going to get that
really junky Starbucks drink in the
morning you're unlikely to be healthy
the rest of the day you're unlikely to
follow through and all the other goals
you set you're going to do so why so
important to have a morning routine that
set you up for success this is probably
the topic of my next book or at least a
good chunk of it I find a lot of people
once they find their one word it's super
helpful it's really powerful how do you
make sure that you live your one word
every single day and it comes from
starting up with a great morning routine
now these are seven strategies I'm going
to share with you today you'll
necessarily have to apply all of them to
your life what I encourage you to do is
test one at a time for a week just test
adding this one thing to your morning
routine for the week and see do you feel
better you have more energy was it a
waste of time like all you've lost is a
few minutes every day for one week right
but the upside is tremendous so test
each one out and let me know which one
works best for you so the first way to
start your perfect day off is to get up
get rid of the snooze button now while
some of you'll be throwing tomatoes at
me now or cooking away your Dickens of
that snooze button let's talk about some
of the reasons why you shouldn't be
snoozing first off
science is proven it's actually bad for
you you actually feel a lot more groggy
if you just hear the alarm and you get
up you're much more likely to have an
energized morning where if you snooze
and then you smooth your brain falls
back asleep and then gets up but in the
fall asleep and then gets back up again
and while that may feel good in the
short term you're going to have a couple
hours of grogginess that will not help
you the other thing is on a subconscious
level you're training yourself to fail
you're training yourself to say this is
a goal that I had
and I didn't do it right my goal is to
wake up with his time and I didn't do it
I'm snoozing I didn't do it as soon as
again I didn't do it again you're
training yourself that it's okay to set
a goal for yourself for a new habit and
not follow through and since how you're
starting every single day you're
starting the day by saying it's okay to
let myself down and disappoint myself
again that is not a powerful way to
start your day so that combined with a
science get up put your clock somewhere
else across the room whatever strategy
you want to use it doesn't matter stop
pressing the snooze button and just get
up number two
drink some water your body 60% water
your brain is 75% water one of the main
reasons why you're so tired in the
morning is you're dehydrated you sweat a
lot of water out over night you've just
been sleeping for five six seven eight
nine hours without any hydration you
need to get up and not reach for coffee
but reach for a glass of water it will
make you feel better the scientists
truth is one of the most consistent
things that I think really everybody
should be doing to give themselves more
energy in the morning on top of having
more energy and feeling less tired
drinking water will help you lose weight
and will help you fight off sicknesses
as well and as a special bonus I'd say
try adding some lemon to your water too
adding some lemon to your water in the
morning will give you vitamin C to help
boost your immune system will allow you
to have better skin and will fight bad
breath as well a good tip is if you're
under 150 pounds at half a lemon to your
water and if you're over 150 pounds add
the full lemon into your water and makes
a difference stop reaching for coffee
reach for water first
[Music]
number three is music music is so so so
so important because it changes your
state when a good song comes on that
makes you want to bounce it instantly
lifts your mood it instantly gives you
more energy and so I have a believ
playlist and one of the things that I do
is every morning I wake up and with my
wife and put on a dance song that we
both enjoy and we dance and we agree
when we dance with each other it's a
good time to bond but also to get us
shaken to give us energy
and I would encourage you to make your
own playlist think about songs that make
you want to move that make you just when
it comes on you have to bounce you have
to get excited and start your day with
that so that you have energy in the
morning after drinking a glass of water
and you're ready to take on today
[Music]
number four is gratitude it's impossible
to be grateful for something and really
sad and depressed and angry at the same
time and so I find it really helpful to
have a quick morning gratitude session
just to think about three things that
I'm grateful for for the day and so it's
something I do with my wife we'll wake
up
we'll grab a glass of water we'll then
dance to a song and then we'll sit down
for four minutes another song will come
on it's calm and peaceful relaxing new
lyrics and we'll just put our hand over
our heart and think of three things that
we're grateful for for that day and I
think that really helps set us up just
the awareness the shift in perspective
the not complaining about the things of
outside our control and just recognizing
that we have a lot of amazing things
that we have in our lives and not only
focusing on the things that we don't
have for my view it's not just
recognizing what's great it's also the
frustration you want more right like I'm
equally happy with what I have and so
good for for it and I wanted I want more
I want to go out and have a bigger
impact like what I've done is not enough
someone just rest and what's happened
but if you only focus on this part of
one aim or one anymore one anymore
and not focusing on what you already
have and how great life is then you're
never going to be hacked and so I find
it that combination is really really
helpful
[Music]
number five is review your goals for the
day I find it really helpful to have a
plan for the day and if you look at
successful people they often have a plan
they know their outcome for what they
want to accomplish for the day again if
you don't have a plan you can guarantee
that everybody else around you has a
plan for you right people have a plan
for you if you open up your email
there's a whole bunch of people who have
a plan for you and a plan for your time
where you need to fight for that time
you need to fight for what you want to
do and so we're viewing your goal -
remembering what am I trying to do today
what's my outcome today what I want to
accomplish today and start setting up
walls for yourself to say nobody is
going to crush through these chunks of
time because
this is what I want to get done today
and so we're viewing that in the morning
reviewing that consistently reviewing
that every day allows you to have a more
powerful day where you're more likely to
follow through on your goals if you
can't remember what your goals are
you're probably not going to get them
accomplishing today number six is
exercise this is another way to change
your state right if you're sleepy and
you're like this and you're complaining
you're probably not going to feel really
powerful if you get up you drink some
water
you put on some music you do a quick
exercise you do jumping jacks you do
some push-ups for me I take my dog Timo
for a walk you sitting out here that's
why I pointed I you can't see one camera
buddy like you one pointed am getting
some kind of exercise in the morning
gets your body movement gets the blood
pump and gets things flowing even if
it's 30 seconds of jumping jacks just
something at the end of our walk we'll
run up 13 flights of stairs and we'll
both be like panting and tired but I
feel great energized and ready to take
on the day so adding some form of
physical activity doesn't have to be
half an hour walk could be thirty
seconds of jumping jacks is at a high
intensity just to get the blood flowing
will make a different spirit if you look
and number seven is being inspired it's
really important I've talked about this
a lot of my videos to have an
environment for success that whenever
you felt energized excited motivated
bold and powered one of the great things
what was it that caused that and put
that into your daily routine
so you have your goals right you have we
have your list of goals that you want to
accomplish you're reading those through
and still that voice in your head that
will say you can't do that who are you
to think that that's going to happen
right that's that's it that's never
going to happen for you you need to
voice it say I'm going to crush these
things you know remember who you are
these things are powerful you're going
to go and kill it you can do this and so
if it's watching a video or listening to
a podcast or reading a book or whatever
it is however long it takes you to get
in that state of feeling powerful and
unstoppable you want to do that daily
it's why I have the interesting series
in the morning as a video series to help
me get energized to be hanging around a
successful person for 10 minutes to give
me a boost to make me not just give me a
strategy what I can do but
the motivation when you are around other
successful people you instantly become
more successful when you're around
hard-working people you instantly want
to start working harder if you're around
please slow apathetic people it's really
hard you're going to become lazy and
apathetic where you know you have a
higher gear you know you could play
stronger you know you can go faster you
know you can get up there so you need to
design that environment you can design
that into your morning routine so that
you're living in space so those are my
seven ways on how to start the perfect
day I'd love to know what did you think
what did you learn from this video which
one was your favorite way leave it down
the comments below do you want to add an
8 9 10 that I haven't thought of I'd
love to hear your thoughts leave it
below as well I also want to give a
quick shout out to Martha Magdalene a
lifestyle design thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and reviewing it making a video in
your channel I really appreciate your
support
aimes I hope you enjoyed the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love
[Music]